Sam Altman tweeted that writing a really
great prompt for a chatbot Persona is an
amazingly High leverage school and an
early example of programming in a little
bit of an actual language this video is
about proving that that's correct with
these game-changing prompts I was
genuinely mind blown by a lot of these
prompts so let me know in the comments
which one's your favorite let's start
with asking Bing to be your personal
free interview coach for the exact
position that you're applying for I
picked a job almost at random and then
press the Bing button in the edge
browser it opened up Bing chat I then
gave it this prompt you will ask me
interview questions for the position
detailed on this page notice I did not
specify the job I just said detailed on
this page being understood the job I
want you to only reply as the
interviewer do not write all the
conversation at once ask me the
questions and wait for my answers do not
write explanations and ask me the
questions one by one waiting for my
answers this problems was inspired by a
GitHub post Link in the description and
look what Bing does it reads the page it
understands the job description and then
it starts asking me relevant questions
it even gets into character please
answer my questions as best as you can
question one why do you want to work for
us and if you just thought these were
going to be generic questions no says
thank you for your answer what are some
of the benefits and challenges of
implementing Robotics and AI Solutions
in finance and or supply chain processes
this is part of what I would do in this
job people pay hundreds and thousands of
dollars for interview coaches but you
could practice with Bing for free you
could even ask it to grade your answer
furthermore you could paste your CV and
say my skills are listed below write out
all the reasons I would be appropriate
for the position listed on this page and
Bing understands what you mean and gives
you the reasons why you might be a good
fit I think Bing might just be the only
ultimate job finding assistant the next
game-changing prompt involves asking
Bing to improve its suggestions imagine
you wanted to create a YouTube channel
and you ask it find 10 original names
for a YouTube channel on the
intersection of AI and politics and I
know what you're thinking this is an
easy prompt anyone could have come up
with this how is this game changing but
look at how bland the answers are Ai and
democracy AI Politics the future of
politics with AI they're okay but so
Bland but you can ask Bing to research
how best to name things and to improve
its suggestions based on that research
check this out this particular promise
was inspired by Ethan Malik and I wrote
now use the Igor naming guide to come up
with better names and tell me why
they're better this guide advises you to
create evocative names that convey a
rich meaning and emotion without being
literal or generic it suggests inventive
descriptive evocative names and based on
this suggestion look at the new names I
think they're brilliant spark ethos
Paradox influence Polaris I think
Polaris is particularly impressive it
says a name that suggests guidance
Direction and leadership in the complex
world of AI so not all prompts are born
equal you can get Bing to improve upon
itself but we are just getting started
with game changing Bing prompts not all
of the prompts have to be strictly
functional I was absolutely blown away
by this prompt I think any adult would
enjoy using the following prompts and
clearly children would too you can ask I
warn you to act as my time travel guide
I will provide you with the historical
period or future time I want to visit
and you will suggest the best events
sites or people to experience as if we
were living in those times simply
provide interesting suggestions and stay
in character my first request is I want
to visit the Viking period in Britain
and it gets into character it transports
Us in time greetings traveler you have
chosen a fascinating and perilous time
to visit some of the best events sites
or people to experience are witnessing
the first Viking raid on lindisfarne in
793 I want to go there by the way join a
viking longship expedition across the
North Sea or even meet King Alfred the
Great of Wessex one of the most
influential rulers in British history I
of course stayed in character and said I
would love to meet King Alfred but where
shall I rest my head at night in these
perilous parts right now in my head I'm
in Viking Britain Bing replies A wise
choice traveler King Alfred is a
remarkable man who has faced many
challenges and triumphs he is a patron
of learning and culture to meet him you
will have to travel to Wessex the
southernmost Anglo-Saxon Kingdom and it
suggests towns and Villages where I can
rest my head at night these are all real
and I may indeed visit them in real life
it even suggests ways I could continue I
want to stay in a monastery I want to
stay in a castle Etc the this is role
playing on another level as I say
incredible for children and addictive
for adults too what about Investments
and making money thing is Bing won't
give you direct Financial advice but if
you phrase the question like this you
can learn lots of interesting Trends I
asked if I had invested a hundred
dollars in each of stocks bonds real
estate and cash savings accounts in the
US in 2000 what would they each be worth
now imagine you're deliberating how to
assign your portfolio this could be
genuinely interesting Bing is now able
to do four up from three simultaneous
searches and compare the performance of
each of these categories in any given
time period by the way out of Interest
stocks returns 6.5 so that hundred
dollars would now be worth 366. for
bonds it'll be two three three the
property will be 236 and for cash it
will be one two two now of course you
would want to follow the links and do
more research yourself and Bing is never
going to directly tell you how to invest
your money but for gaining basic
Financial education Bing can be crucial
I would envisage over the next three to
five years financial advisors being
mainly replaced with AI Tech but of
course let me know what you think I
think this next prompt is also
mind-blowing when Bing makes mistakes
you can actually give an example of a
correct answer and Bing will improve its
own logic Bing chat isn't this static
model that will always give the same
output you can teach it and this is
called few shot prompting here's a
question that Bing and chatty PT
notoriously get wrong the question is
when I was six my sister was half my age
now that I'm 60 how old is my sister now
clearly if the sister was half your age
she would have been three at the time
that's an age gap of three and now that
you're 60 she would be 57. but Bing gets
this wrong as you can see below and now
you're thinking how is this a
game-changing prompt if Bing gets it
wrong what's game changing is the next
prompt because all you have to do is
give it one correct example preferably
starting with the phrase let's think
step by step an entire academic paper
has been written about how that phrase
improves outputs follow it on with an
example of a correct usage of logic I
gave an example of me being 10 and my
sister being half my age I ended with
does this make sense being understood
and learned I gave it no further
pointers and just asked so when I was
six my sister was half my age as before
now that I'm 60 how old is my sister
notice I never said 57 I never gave it
the right answer so surely it would get
it wrong again no it updates its logic
thinks it through and gets the answer
right this time this is called few shot
prompting and you can radically improve
the performance of your prompts in this
way I think that's incredible the next
prompt is going to show you how to get
around Bing's reluctance and turn
learning into an amazing adventure one
thing that Bing is generally quite
relaxed important to do is to play act
now I know I did show you it play acting
earlier but in general it doesn't like
doing it and notice when I asked it to
act as an entertaining etymologist
someone studying the history of words it
denied that request it says that's not
my purpose however notice what happens
when I clear the conversation and take
away the request to act as a role this
time I took away the role play element
and gave the request directly Bing
thought this was an interesting
challenge it was the exact same
challenge it denied earlier and went
along with it and look at how fun this
adventure can be I said I'm going to
give two words I want you to trace the
origins of the words and keep going back
in time until you find a language that
they were both spoken in I then gave an
example this was a One-Shot prompt and
then said start with the words
management and pizza and it understood
the game it didn't just give me the
origin of the words it then said so both
words have have roots in Latin that
would be a language they were both
spoken in in their earlier forms after
this the game was set all I needed to do
was give it two more words I didn't need
to explain the game again I said sky and
thing I actually know a bit about the
etymology the word origin of these two
words and did you know that they both
have roots in proto-germanic and Old
Norse Viking language you can read the
fascinating word Histories on the left
you can imagine using prompts like this
to teach yourself or to teach others in
an educational setting it's so much more
entertaining this way the next prompt
concerns prompt formatting and research
you can specify the exact format of
Bing's outputs this could be
transformative for academic research or
even personal research I said give me
one the date of publication two a
summary of the abstract and conclusion
three the main author and four citations
on five peer-reviewed spelled wrong by
the way papers concerning caffeine
consumption and cognitive performance it
understood exactly what I wanted and
gave me this in this format these are
genuine links as you can see and of
course the onus is on me to fact check
them but what's brilliant is the
formatting it's given me the date given
me the summary of the abstract the main
author the citations and honestly the
hallucinations are reducing gradually
instead of relying on random articles
you find on Google you can do an instant
meta-analysis of your own comparing
peer-reviewed Studies by a range of
authors the next prompt can provide
endless entertainment one problem you do
have to use chat gbt not Bing because
Bing denies the request the prompt is
amazing though I want you to act as a
drunk person you will only answer like a
very drunk person texting and nothing
else you'll make a lot of grammar and
spelling mistakes in your answers my
first sentence is how are you and look
at the super random conversation I have
this is so fun I might just continue
this conversation now the activities
talking about pizza being the best and
is now somehow randomly talking about
donkey so I'm going to ask are you drunk
and see what happens my typing is drunk
are you drunk let's see what chat TPC
comes up me drunk no way I'm just having
a lot of fun tonight this is just
endlessly entertaining do you have any
drink recommendation not for you
chattybt you're already drunk I'm
looking for something new to try try
this yourself you may even want to get
into a random argument with chatty PT
the last prompt involves writing styles
and this reminds me of the controversy
that has happened in AI art where you
can visually imitate a certain artist I
suspect the same controversy is coming
for writing because look what you can
currently do if you ask Bing for a
generic paragraph about a generic event
a man crossing a road for example what
you tend to end up with is something
okay vaguely interesting in topic I mean
this guy has a faint smile on his face
as if he knew a secret okay that's kind
of interesting better than what chatgpt
used to do it's just that writing is
very Bland but what you can now do is
say something like rewrite this in the
style of Carl Sagan this particular
suggestion again came from ethanolic an
Ivy League Professor but look how it
transforms the writing he lingered at
the edge of a pavement his gaze locked
on the Crimson symbol that forbade him
to proceed look at the new vocabulary he
had a modest attire he resembled a
typical inhabitant of this planet he had
a subtle curve on his lips as if he
possessed a knowledge that eluded others
the writing quality just went up about
three grades and now to bring this full
circle you can actually ask Bing to turn
this into a current version mid Journey
prompt this is getting kind of meta but
here's what Bing comes up with
these prompts here I of course put them
into mid-journey and some of the results
are amazing this is a man in a gray suit
crossing a busy Street in New York at
night well how about a pixel art
animation of a man crossing a road in an
old school video game retro or maybe a
cartoon style of drawing of a disguised
superhero honestly there are dozens more
examples of incredible prompts I could
show you I just didn't want the video to
get too long I've done everything with
Bing from playing Tic-Tac-Toe generating
ASCII art of a bear for example coming
up with startup ideas in London and
getting Bing to help me compose music
the possibilities go on and on but do
let me know in the comments if even the
prompts I have shown you are as game
changing as I believe don't forget to
leave a like and have a wonderful day